new season of total Bella's is often
running of course Nikki and Brie are
both expecting yep they are pregnant at
the same time and we talked about the
difficulties of going through all of
that during a pandemic can I see the
bumps how are you guys doing this isn't
when I match in my first pregnancy to be
you know I had a really important
appointment and adding to the stress
Brie's husband Brian was quarantined
last month after returning from Florida
where he was filming WWE Smackdown
without an audience and the action was
having some breathing issues so he had a
test done but he tested negative for the
virus and then I was like okay now
you're like to come right now breathe
Brian their daughter birdie
along with Nicky and Artem ourself
isolating in Arizona where they are
next-door neighbors I have a baker in
the house and now I get cravings and I
want cinnamon rolls and there's no where
to buy Easton less $500 on your
quarantine period is incredible he's
obsessed and then he's just a bush man
Nikki and Artem's wedding plans are on
hold for now and the twins just passed
their halfway point and their
pregnancies brie is due in late July
Nikki in early August were you planning
on letting the cameras into the births
yes so we both were gonna have two
people in the room
I just put my iPhone up and we're just
gonna do that raw live footage
[Music]